la neige vous êtes place du palais royal
c'est gilet jaune espère donc
interpeller le pouvoir et protester
contre les interdictions de manifester
aujourd'hui
et oui ça va être compliqué ans sophie
puisque cette manifestation elle s'est
terminée presque avant de commencer donc
c'est gilet jaune ici présents avaient
pour ambition de défiler devant les
lieux de pouvoir
le sénat l'assemblée nationale et
ministère de l'intérieur matignon pour
arriver en fin de journée à l'elysée
puis ça ne sera pas possible puisque les
déclarants ont décidé de mettre un terme
à cette manifestation puisqu'ils ont en
main maintenant désormais les
interdictions de manifester donc pour
éviter des peines en justice je suis
avec nadine nadia nadia mehrani donc
vous avez décidé de stopper cette
manifestation ce qu'on n'a pas le choix
alors il faut savoir que là on a un
arrêté donc nous les déclarant quand on
a un arrêté
si on reste après l'arrêté qui nous met
dans les mains ça vaut 7500 euros
d'amendé et six mois d'emprisonnement
ferme vous rendez compte que pour juste
rester sur une déclaration qu'on a faite
préalablement on l'a déclaré tout est
nickel
mais si dès qu'ils nous mettent
l'arrêter dans les mains on doit
malheureusement appelé à la dispersion
et nous déclarant ne plus être là ce qui
d'ailleurs si je peux me permettre
la semaine dernière à a coûté on va dire
on le reste aurait pu coûter cher à
monsieur fawzia parce que lui pareil ils
étaient déclarant la semaine dernière il
a eu l'arrêter mais l'après-midi et l'a
été dans un élite et dans un quartier où
il y avait ri s'est retrouvé avec
d'autres j'ai les jaunes c'est encore
mieux comme un pape et josé lellouche
déclarant malade mais voilà et ben
résultats comme il s'est retrouvé avec
une un groupe de personnes alors qu'ils
avaient une interdiction résultats
automatiquement il a été mis en garde à
vue donc il a fait 24 heures de garde à
vue et mercredi on l'a signifié que
classée sans suite parce qu'il n'y avait
pas de problème on a déjà vous me dit
j'arrête la manifestation parce que la
préfecture de police me l'a interdit
mais vous saviez
nadia que que la préfecture de police
allait interdire ce parcours cela fait
plus de dix mois qui l'on interdit aussi
les jeunes de manifester devant les
lieux de pouvoir
on est bien d'accord mais je pars du
principe que ça fait depuis le 5
décembre que le pays est en grève et
vous avez tous les syndicats qui peuvent
manifester devant les lieux de pouvoir
vous avez la manif pour tout ce qui peut
se faire une place statique devant le
sénat vous avez des avocats qui peuvent
aller à la presse au ministère de la
justice
dites moi moi nadia simple citoyenne
pourquoi je n'ai pas les mêmes droits
qu'on explique juste ça qu'on me dit
pourquoi le peuple n'a pas les mêmes
droits au regard des failles et ça se
fait raccompagner
on a à peine dispersés voyez ce que je
veux dire il attendait qu'on le dise
dispersés pour tout de suite se met en
place mais deux jeux d'hier voilà moi
comme explique donc monsieur l'allemand
il a bien dit on n'est pas dans le même
camp apparemment c'est une partie de la
population qui n'est pas dans le même
camp que des simples citoyens
je sais pas moi comme l'expliquent moi
je vous savez je suis quelqu'un de très
compréhensive moi j'aime bien comprendre
les choses
voilà ma com explique simplement qu'on
m'explique si je la déclare pas je suis
illégal si je la déclarent qu'ils
mettent un arrêté je ne peux plus la
faire à quel moment je peux la faire
alors c'est tout et là en plus on vous
dit ah non vous donne un parcours mais à
quel moment dans la constitution c'est
marqué que manifester c'est je dois
demander un parcours donc dans ces cas
là qui me mettent aussi bah tiens pas
qu'il me mette à bruxelles parce que de
toute façon c'est là bas qu'on devrait
manifester bas qui me le donne à
bruxelles et qui loupait d'écart ya
beaucoup de manifestants qui m'ont
confié aujourd'hui qu'en france on il ne
se sentait plus ils sont plus avoir le
droit de manifester librement à ce que
c'est votre cas amusez-vous le pense et
ne plus avoir le droit de manifester à
l'erreur la preuve encore aujourd'hui on
l'a déclaré et nous disent que c'est pas
possible
alors pour nous le samedi c'est pas
possible d'assurer la sécurité des
institutions est toute la semaine ils
peuvent l'assurer pour les autres
syndicats y'a pas un problème
donc la semaine on peut la salle
sécurisée
donc peut-être effectivement un tiens
vous me donner une bonne idée
peut-être déclaré la semaine le même
lieu le même parcours mais la semaine
puisque apparemment ils peuvent le
sécuriser que la semaine et le week-end
pour nous les gilet jaune alors que je
dis bien
on n'a aucun gilet jaune moi je suis
avant tout une citoyenne qui fait partie
du mouvement des gilet jaune parce que
c'est important ce qu'on revendique et
ben c'est impossible c'est le sam est
interdite donc je voudrais comprendre
pourquoi c'est justement ça et
aujourd'hui encore une fois on fait le
ont fait bien on démontre bien qu'il est
impossible dans notre soi disant
démocratie de manifester pour une
certaine catégorie
attention on est toujours en train de
dire mais si tu vois bien en démocratie
les gens manifestent non une certaine
catégorie de la population peut
manifester en librement et une autre
partie de la population elle est en
dictature
il ya bien un problème stature c'est pas
osé alors matheron l'a bien défini moi
c'est pas moi qui l'a dit à dictature il
y eut bien une personne et un groupe de
personnes qui décident pour tout le
monde
la réforme retraites personne l'aveu
c'est bien lui elles sont assemblées
majoritaire qui décide pour tout le
monde donc je suis désolé il a donné lui
même la définition comme il avait dit si
vous votez le pen on sera dans le chaos
envolés en vouloir on veut arrêter vous
voulez dire allez-y votez pour moi je
vais vous mettre le chaos c'est tout
c'est comme ça qu'il faut le comprendre
quand tu parles nedjam errani merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes co déclarante de
cette manifestation aujourd'hui en
manifestation qui s'est donc terminée
puisqu'il n'y a plus aucun manifestant
sur cette place de la bourse se place
cette place du palais-royal pardon alors
qu'on a toujours un important dispositif
de sécurité autour de cette place donc
voilà une manifestation qui s'est donc
terminée aussi vite qu'elle a commencé
merci beaucoup nadège un terrain vague
depuis donc la place du palais royal à
proximité du conseil d'état de